I didn't watch that much soccer you have
to admit in the past but you start
watching a lot of it you learn new
things one of my favorite things are the
goal celebrations have you seen those
some of them some of the teams worked
out these really elaborate goal
celebrations here's a famous one from a
team in Iceland check it out
[Applause]
I thought that was pretty elaborate but
guess what that is nothing compared to
this epic celebration from a match
yesterday check this out celebration
they're celebrating in midfield and they
are sitting down he looks like he's
miming and microphone and he looks like
he's pretending that he's a stand-up
comedian and he's doing a stand-up looks
like he's throwing over pretty well with
the crowd doing some crowd work they're
loving his material and here comes
another player pretending to be a
cocktail waitress minding the cocktails
I have to get two cocktails okay what
are they doing now
it looks like playing some scene oh it's
a few good men here he comes
you can't handle the truth great scene
okay what's the 710 split and he missed
it
The Price is Right and they've gotten an
opposing player to pretend he's a
refrigerator
show-off the crisper and it looks like
it's time for him to oh yeah spin the
giant clickety clackety wheel great
space work here comes the referee this
has been a really long celebration he
doesn't know what to do about it he's
running up to the booth hey they're not
giving him any go he looks like he won
The Price is Right
he was another celebrating his Price is
Right win with another celebration
what's this
it looks like oh and oh it's Ned Stark
from Game of Thrones good guy who's the
angry black bear in the foreground
[Applause]
you